[музика]
з чепе в руку туман в Україні наді та
савченко у багатих щось зачинила вся а
нині
масу викликаного чого заради тоді
допоможи кремлю чарівників по розмови за
лідером з апарату stiu мінську в обсі
тристоронньої контактної групи з
донбасу
у team у євросоюзі сам ідеальний
савченко з зловити знач нас покинеш вони
в Україні фермент дужку css
мінський процес душа складні тому надій
савченко я шлюб уманду валу не включають
вихідного сильно умінський процес ім
роман безус мінськ обхід з анти зовнішнім
ви на
і чи маєш активне добувати і
себе тварина українці столітті прибуває на
сході україни обидві росії для україни
урал сланці в Європі активно боролася
через ланку не надій савченко
франк-вальтер штайнмаєр їду у москву на
переговори євро депутати посварилися
список санкцій савченко фаршем новим
я комів стати владимир путін нині коліно
дія на волі повіт на майдані
на бачиш іншої форми fisheye тисніть
допомагає до створення катя сподівається чен і
вас меблі
петля дверна савченко російські медіа
розгорнули масштабну кампанію проти
нейту про ти українського істеблішменту
ванна і душ від сили з прямого але
намазалась створений би ти савченком і
просто забуті снейпу сміху військам метод
всього на мою думку без кредиту вати
савченко q в україні душа любили а інету
світіння стоянка ви наївність стала в
приводі російським пропагандистам
вони савченко вже на входи до партії
Батьківщина тов Roxio Верховній Раді
збирати піт з і за і виключення з
парламентського комітету спитати
національну б стопі та оборони а
також здала готті україни у хлопця у
Євросоюзі його шкода знайду сильним так
ребекка хармс paragon вона зараз
савченко на агент кремля а молоді кулі
так з первинним dos виглядом покаравши танька
відхід на ідею савченка унікальний і
приковувало людині наймаючи
політичному і звіду
і нагороди газу миша все знаємо у yax
клаусі і жити а на речі і з брехова ти
явно не на біса на інструмент кремля
я обожнюю притягнутим за вухом інструмент
тоскани шлюб політичного та звіду того
1 годину на нього вірна приймуть
there is надій савченко одна сторона
називають досвіду не дойче велле політек
це експерти і сам іван і поставив і удари
з політичної кар'єри вже на porsche
їх сходинках